okay now i hope you've got the basic
details of the question down now like
the stuff up in this paragraph i want
you to have a look very very quickly at
a through f see what is asking you and
then see if you understand my arm my
concise version of what the questions
are asked here right max hi type it next
time the new version of x double dot
because remember i said to you it turns
around make a whole new change your
direction redefine everything how
plastic over it hits and how's that
compare to how fast it was prevented
okay are you happy with those questions
yeah so now let's go with this puppy now
where would you like me to start to
prove this like I said it's not it's not
complicated where did I stop my last one
it was he pushed me already yeah okay
solo a riot and you should write F
equals MA go ahead and write it it's a
you you wouldn't believe when people
aren't doing mechanics questions how
many but don't write F equals MA and
then the next slide it's like just some
random stuff that uses the numbers and
some letters like some combination of X
viene I if you say F equals MA you'll
save yourself from some very very basic
points ok so I'm going to say firstly if
the hay but along with that I need to
find what's going on here okay I need to
have a scheme that will make this in
particular the signs and all that kind
of thing I need to skin to make sense of
that right so I need to know a starting
point and I need to know what's up and
what's down okay so where would you like
me to get would you like me to call the
urgent okay all right let up be positive
and I need an origin what do you think
is a suitable origin for this first bit
I can't hold on a second i can't say x
equals 0 because X equal 0
definition is the origin so I need to
tell me what is x equals zero what would
you like to be okay so i think probably
the foreground is fine i'm going to call
it the point of projection because i
might not be on the ground i could be
like up in the air or something like
that so i'm going to say let up a
positive and oh the point of projection
that's all you need okay excellent so
now I say F equals M a Fink have you got
the important details in the question
what should I fill in to both sides of
this okay so they have a look at what
the question is asking you have already
told you which form of a to do so i'm
going to say X dot line now the forces
over here they're going to be two things
right there's gravity which way is it
going in our scheme yeah it's negative
okay and then you've got air resistance
in our scheme we are traveling up at the
moment right so which was a resistance
i'm also down the case they've both in
the video so I'm going to say over you
negative the first office gravity right
today to find out in force or do they
just leave it as JD it's just Jake ok so
this is 1g it's all right and then
there's the other negative thing air
resistance ok so it's negative zero
point zero different tune not very
surgery yeah cool ok that's fine so this
this straight substitution it's a little
bit like see how I put these ones here
when you were asking me like but but it
isn't that it like isn't that there and
you remember ones are hiding there and
we should put them in a similar way to
when I say this if I say this ok I know
it's a bit trivial to write that is five
times one but I want you to write five
times one because I want you to tell me
I know what that means ok in the same
way I masters doesn't just disappear it
hang in there so now i will rearrange
and I'm factor out and that's where the
request eight in total so far so good
right puppy find the maximum height all
right so when you have a look at this
how am I going to get from here to a
maximum height this is Part B ok so
there's lots of different ways i can go
about this the way I'm thinking about is
I again have to choose a form for
acceleration this one's useless in here
okay it's nice and concise but does it
tell me it doesn't give me a future
direction so I need to choose one of
these that will get me to where is it
the maximum I'm okay so which do you
think is like we've set an appt some
height is going to be when we're
velocity is zero a characteristic so i'm
going to say i'm actually going to write
this right since our goal is related to
maximum height which is actually a
velocity goal right is related to
velocity okay i'm going to choose okay
so have a look what are you ready
oh okay now here's what I want you to
keep in mind remember these are all
different ways of saying same thing and
also if you can call you my bag to me
didn't extension one these are
particularly close together very quickly
in fact but there's only really one or
two lines in between going from one to
the other okay now if you like you're
welcome to have a go I mean there's big
reasons to choose this look there's a V
squared so V squared there right the way
I solved it I just chose this one you'll
see both of them will work out I'm going
to go with v DV on DX okay it's a her
work I guess if you want to try see how
this big tin Chi square on DX see what
happens so over here i'm going to write
v DV on the x equals okay good I go to
you slow down slow down ok so I'm going
to get this meeting over there on the
right course I'm so this is going to be
this 100 words r equals to P with yellow
numbers okay know what let's forget to
that be
I to integrate right the so I nature's
take your brain double ring this live up
here
come into that time okay now what am I
going to do with this where is this
going to go you need like it's going to
be okay so this whole thing by the way I
should point out is a little bit messy
because it's 0.02 guy what I don't think
so what I'm gonna do is a little
multiply through both sides both sorry
top and bottom by 50 now get rid of this
because then I don't have to worry about
this is a closet of mark because I could
just take that out ok so this dfw V is
negative 50 v on 50 g plus v square that
look okay all right now I'm almost ready
to integrate I'm going to need all that
one space on your stay over here okay
this is going to be waste is what does
this look like well this is a snapshot
out almost right I need to take our fat
to roll thank you a negative 25 that'll
make me with a two V and a V squared so
that's exactly what i want so i'm going
to write d amps on DV I'll take out that
negative 25 my suggestion and that
leaves me with 2 V on 50 G Plus this
method sound good now I'm ready to
actually enjoy
okay looking good what do you think this
is a pretty messy cool sites on food
yeah so sorry yes okay so when I have
integrated that negative 25 he hands out
over here log of what ya basta pasta
okay all right great question now look
back at the question I believe the
question tells you an initial velocity
right in the first sentence it says
particle mass one kilo projected
vertically upwards from the ground with
a speed of and it's pretty hard to see
but they say capital means then a little
bit it's actually harder to read the
difference okay so capital e is my
initial velocity to have a look when x
equals 0 that's my point of projection
the velocity is capital v okay and then
there's a constant there so when this is
0 what will happen this guy is just
going to come over the other side to
give you the constant than you need
right so I'm going to say substituting
in x equals 0 that's going to leave me
to this
yeah so I'm glad you mentioned that
because of these are so easy to make
something this actually happens quite
frequently right I write my visa really
huge and I had a tail front of them okay
just so it's I mean it's just like
saying this right it's just so I don't
mock up myself ok so that's the rumor
busy now put that beer a little bit all
right so remember where I'm going to try
to find max height ok so what I've got
is an expression for fina this is
positive i would put out the front so 25
longer this and take away 25 log that ok
so what are we going to do with this to
get the maximum plan ok great i'm
finding where this velocity this
velocity is 0 ok so i don't even go the
same max hi when there's no velocity ok
sorry you care but the question said my
family who you just the juices of Zijin
if you like the motor homes when the
velocity is 0 so popping that in here
this is called H i think they call it HD
yep the greatest height is H so my
displacement that's what it's called is
going to be 25 log on this this is just
one big messy constant what happens that
guy in the end it's just take away 25
long it's just 53 right yeah i'm going
to factorize out and then i'm going to
combine the long so that gives me with
this
what do you think what's all right messy
but that's because I don't know well
then they've asked me to stay with GE
try the number and i also have no idea
what this actual initial velocities okay